bonsoir l'huma bichat je regarde pas
beaucoup la téloche moi mais j'ai
entendu dire que tu travailles et ça va
être bien la barre faire plein de meuf
un pari que c'est pas ton genre mais
quand même
tu connais du monde là bas pour me faire
entrer je connais quelques personnes
mais à widnes williams amf
elle a gagné là elle a gagné la sacrée
soirée elle a mis la date de sa c'est
pas la naissance de sa grand-mère les
trucs comme ça et il a gagné il a gagné
ça s'emballe un tu le connais faut qu
ils aiment bien faut qu une fois jeune
et j'ai vu alors qu'il sortait de son
avion à marseille et il avait l'air
tellement content de rentrer dans sa
ville que je les je me suis dit voilà ça
c'est un type c'est un type qui est
sympathique communiqué qui aime la vie
et voilà c'est tout il passe quelques
fois à star 92 la star drucker tu le
connais de rigueur car j'adore les
dockers j'adore c'est un type c'est leur
art type c'est l'unique même qui quand
on se plante vous téléphone le lendemain
pour vous dire c'est pas grave tu
passeras à travers cette année encore
actes m
dunkerque m je parie que tu aimes
sébastien aussi c'est ne peut pas dire
du mal de ce type là parce que s'ils
sont là où ils sont on peut ton peuple
on peut on peut dire qu'on n'est pas
comme eux et qu'on veut pas de ce
système là et qu'on veut pas faire les
mêmes choses ça c'est ça c'est un point
mais on sait difficile de dire du mal de
ce qu'ils ont tous quelque chose ou être
à cannes tout le monde quoi en fait un
peut-être genre comme tout le monde
t'aime personnes en fait mais tu dis que
tu aimes tout le monde dames par exemple
sabatier surcôte il est beau c'est un
patrick quintal m sabatier moi je laime
bien sont une relation
curieuse parce qu'on vive absolument pas
du tout dans le même monde et
pourtant il il ya toujours beaucoup de
beaucoup d'attention comme ça et le
résultat ça fait une relation assez
longue et qui marche plutôt bien
elle était un mec misère toi un peu
d'histoire comme ça un peu permet en les
émissions comme ça un peu au-dessous de
la ceinture thème bien comme ça dans le
genre de chavannes ça me prend st j'ai
fait une fois son émission j'en suis par
éthique plutôt bien tiré et je dois dire
que que c'était amusant j'ai part
regretté un qui s'emballe bien gelée vue
là il est allé aux sept d'or la hausse
et zahra était toujours avec des belles
femmes est tous un peu pas ton genre
quoi
montiel laquelle sept ans bernard
montiel adorable et l'autre la paix
n'était pas là non
ppda là c'est un pote à toi aussi le
ppda c'est tout bêtement frère c'est à
dire que j'ai un peu avec ppda la même
relation que j'ai avec michel drucker
adesanya une meuf six coups et l'amener
à villetaneuse
ça décoiffe ray là avec a des manques de
moi car ça va la dance et un civil
claire chazal elle est divine ouais y'a
des mecs là comme ça ils m'ont dit à qui
tu avais un petit béguin la cour
guillaume durand d'un mec comme ça et
solide light ont peur de rien
c'est un très grand jeu l'adorent
guillaume durand alors là si regarde
l'émission je les adore
guillaume durand il est incroyablement
sexy quand on est en contact avec lui
moi il ya ma copine regarde la télé tous
les dimanches
moi c'est pas vraiment mon truc mais
penses tu ailles me laisse tranquille
alors une carte jacques martin thurien
jack martin aussi jacques martin c'est à
la télévision l'équivalent des monstres
sacrés du cinéma
les grands rôles français les arts ea
port où les simone signoret il aimerait
bien [ __ ] j'aimerais vraiment bien
[ __ ] j'aimerais bien coincé un soir aux
folies bergères et tac ont bien réagi st
j'ai deux copains
j'en ai un qui est congolais mon vieux
j'aimerais bien [ __ ] 1 pour voir ce
qu'il dit toujours il allume toujours
tout le monde sait à ce mec là mais je
peux pas l'encadrer qu'ils aimeraient
bien voir comment il est quand et
comment il s'appelle déjà
hérisson art ensemble l'art ensemble
alors à l'essor thierry ardison à cela
je peux vraiment pas le sac et je trouve
vulgaire méchant agressif
physiquement je trouve assez attirant
quand même et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux